le candidat était de l'autre côté du
jardin de crem crié je vais tuer ta mère
et ton père suite à ça on va monter à
l'étagé on pouvait déjà plus j'étais à
bout c'était c'est bon stop vous m'avez
vu hélas encore une fois deux autres
candidats arrivent et une candidate qui
est elle aussi spécialisée dans le
harcèlement mais dit toi tu vas voir tu
as la chance qu'elles vivent à côté de
toi
mais tôt ou tard tu l'a alors cette
gifle tu vas que la manger tu vas te
l'apprendre
donc c'est ça c'est titré freinage allez
me dire qu'il ya une ambiance soit là
d'un film tente une ambiance de violence
de dios mais c'est quoi déjà pas des
appâts de la sécurité il ya pas de la
production et la sécurité mais la
sécurité on a fait pas intervenir mois
plusieurs fois et des séquences où les
candidats par exemple rania a failli se
prendre un coup de poing à un millimètre
de son visage par un candidat
et quand le vigile devant intervenir la
conduction il dit n'intervenant pas
qu'ils ne cassent pas la séquence non si
à savoir que je crois qu'il n'y avait ça
ça n'existe pas de norme avant ouais
parce que ces jeux c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi il ya une la sécurité avant
parce que nous on fait un soir donc avec
une autre candidate qui avec une
l'harcèlement avec moi qui s'appelle
céline lors du tournage des anges aux on
a été en quasiment enterrée vivante en
fait pendant qu'on dormait donc il ya
deux candidats qui sont partis en boîte
de nuit
nous on ne faisait pas partie de cette
séquence dont prophète on est juste
passé se coucher on dormait
tranquillement et en fait on s'est fait
réveiller par une sorte de bruit de
verre brisé et quand on s'est tourné
l'une vers l'autre on s'est vus couverte
de terre et des gros pots de pamiers en
fait qui était sur nous pendant qu'on
dormait de là on appelle le producteur
ce que le producteur était défoncée il
ya de la drogue oui pendant y'en a
réalisé la drogue et moyens il ya de la
drogue d'alcool
il ya là la drogue la production le sait
elle est fournie par la production
elle est fournie par la poterie tournage
moi je sais pas ce que c'est très grave
que oui mais c'est vrai que vous dites
qu'il ya de la drogue qui est fourni par
la production pourquoi c'est pour que
les cc c'est incroyable ce que vous
dites parce que c'est quoi comme drogue
la cocaïne ken cocaïne oui les tournages
se passe en général dans des pays à
l'étranger donc vous était bien que les
candidats vous quoi prendre le risque de
passer les frontières avec de la drogue
cette drogue est là là là si si
j'ai une question que non mais ça ça
c'est un scandale
bah oui c'est un scandale c'est sané
cloud qui parlait mais le parc par
contre j'ai besoin de comprendre
pourquoi vos personne n'a voulu quitter
brutalement la production on avez vous
fait un super g la tête s'il ya de la
drogue quitter on m'a refusé
mais comment on peut vous refuser la
télé ou 3 rue davout n'a plus en plus à
des histoires peut-être qu'il aimait y
passe y que la wii chose mais ça c'est
que sera pas payé ça oui c'est tournage
nous sommes isolés ou sommes nous à
notre famille est loin de nos proches et
ils nous font un véritable travail
psychologique
j'ai voulu quitter le tournage mais
quand je vous dis que j'ai insisté
pendant une heure j'ai dit c'est bon je
ne veux plus je veux partir je veux
rentrer chez moi
le nom angèle on a trop besoin de toi tu
es génial tu es super alors que j'étais
en train de subir un acharnement et est
donc c'est tout un travail psychologique
mais il faut savoir aussi qu il ne passe
pas nos téléphones portables juste angel
rania et nathaniel j'aimerais qu'on
vienne 2 petites secondes sur ce que
vous venez de dire parce que c'est
extrêmement grave c'est même le dit
qu'il ya de la drogue de la cocaïne sur
les tournages de cette télé réalité
qu'elle est fournie par la production
comment ça se passe racontez nous parce
qu on a envie de savoir mais sûrement à
se passer quoi y'a un mec de la
production non prend pas donc on veut
vraiment vous dire qu'il dit là un bon
mais c'est quoi ces des candidats qui
demande à la production c'est un c'est
un secret de polichinelle mais oui ce
sont les candidats qui est qui je ne
savais pas qu allez vous l'avez vu la
production et il en moine en vous mais
d'autres candidates jamais arrivé oui
oui bien sûr il vaut mieux arriver
et enfin je parle bien et la production
elle elle dit quoi elle se dit pas que
ça va leur tomber dessus au moment que
vend maintenant et non ils agissent en
tout entre puissance et ça qui est
incroyable c'est que non et c'est bon
les témoignages sont incroyables d'une
violence inouïe parce que en plus cette
drogue que vous affirmez donc fournie
par la production elle servirait à des
candidats pour être désinhibé faire
qu'ils prennent de la drogue ils sont de
plus en plus violente plus en plus
menaçant c'est ça mais en fait ils ont
des réactions mais complètement
inattendu brillant oui ou pour un non
genre vraiment on peut se prendre enfin
moi j'ai fait me prendre une bougie pour
une sorte de g pas faire un câlin
la bonne personne le matin j'ai pas fait
un câlin là à une fille en première je
me suis retrouvé mon lit par terre une
villa à dos et une bougie qui a failli
me me voler au visage